Find the slope of a
line perpendicular
to the line 3x plus
2y is equal to 6.
So if I have one line-- so let
me draw some quick axes here.
So that's my y-axis,
and that is my x-axis.
And let's say I have a line
here that has a slope of m,
so the slope over
here is equal to m.
A line that is
perpendicular to this line
would intersect
it at 90 degrees,
so it would look
something like this.
This would be a 90 degree angle.
And the slope here-- and I
won't prove it in this video,
we talk about it in other
videos-- the slope here
is going to be equal to
the negative reciprocal
of this line slope.
So it's going to be the negative
reciprocal of that slope,
or another way it's going to
be negative 1 over this slope,
or the negative reciprocal.
Now, with that out of the
way, if we could figure out
the slope of this
line right over here,
we would just have to take
the negative reciprocal,
and we would have the slope
of the perpendicular line.
So let's figure out
the slope of this line.
So let me rewrite it.
3x plus 2y is equal to 6.
And the easiest thing
to do is to solve for y,
so we get it into y
equals mx plus b form,
and then the slope
will be pretty obvious.
So let's get rid of the
x on the left-hand side,
so let's subtract x-- 3x from
both sides, I should say.
And then the left-hand side,
we're left with just a 2y.
The right-hand side, we
have a negative 3x plus 6.
Now we can divide
both sides by 2,
so we have to divide all the
terms on the right-hand side
by 2.
We get y is equal to
negative 3/2x-- that's
that part right
over there-- plus 3.
So the slope of
this line right over
here that they give us--
the slope of this line, now
that we've put it in mx plus
b form, slope-intercept form,
we know that the slope of
this line is negative 3/2.
That is the slope.
So the slope of a line that
is perpendicular to this
will be the negative
reciprocal of this.
So the negative of a
negative is a positive,
so it's going to be a positive.
And then the reciprocal
of 3/2 is going to be 2/3.
So the negative
reciprocal of negative 3/2
is positive 2/3, so we're done.
That's the slope of a line that
is perpendicular to this one
right over here.